mais dans l'urgence avant même la prise
de médicaments ce qui sauve ce sont
quelques gestes de bon sens la croix
rouge organise des initiations aux
premiers secours l'an dernier 200 mille
personnes ont ainsi appris les gestes
d'urgence en marge de la traditionnelle
collecte qui aura lieu ce week-end jenny
briffa et mathieu dreujou elle la
bénévole la plus sexy de la croix rouge
je suis devenue formatrice moi alors je
peux confirmer si vous avez formatrice
aux premiers secours comme quinze mille
autres bénévoles
adriana connaît bien les gestes qui
sauvent mais ce soir là le prof d jean
michel savard vient ainsi principaux
s'effectue en 10 heures de cours les
apprentis secouristes vont apprendre les
principaux gestes qui sauvent la
pédagogie des cas pratiques où tout le
monde joue le mannequin on a en mémoire
c'est tout et on va faire le geste
instantanément 1 et après on va réaliser
que oui effectivement on a sauvé une vie
imagine des situations et là on est
content de faire parce que on sait
comment agir des réflexes acquis par
deux cent mille personnes l'an dernier
grâce à ces formations
celle ci coûte 60 euros mais d'autres
sont totalement gratuites notamment
grâce à ça oui si adrien da n'est pas là
c'est robert qui s'en chargera tout
homme ou emilie 8 yens la quête
nationale de l'argent pour former
toujours plus ça peut être un petit
geste qui n'est peut-être pas aussi
spectaculaire que le beau challenge mais
ça peut être celui là tout petits qui
vous savez
par exemple stopper l'hémorragie par des
fois ils font pression sur les us et
plus rien ne restait que ce sens et ces
personnes qui sont formés aux premiers
secours eux-mêmes ne pourront pas
prévenir les secours et faire les gestes
adaptés
oui aujourd'hui grâce à ces formations
45% des français sont capables d'agir en
cas d'urgence